freunde der sonne wir befinden uns
mitten im anfang der grippesaison die
geht etwa von oktober bis märz wer schon
mal eine richtige grippe weiß das ist
nicht schön aber muss man sich wirklich
dagegen impfen lassen im gegensatz zu
anderen impfungen wie zum beispiel gegen
masern diphtherie tetanus wird die
grippeimpfung nicht allgemein offiziell
empfohlen das heißt sie wird nicht von
der stiko empfohlen von der ständigen
impfkommission die die experten
grundlage liefert für öffentliche
impfempfehlungen aber was bedeutet so
eine stiko empfehlung überhaupt genau
wie gefährlich ist die grippe und wie
gefährlich ist die impf und solltest du
dich diese saison noch impfen lassen das
klären wir jetzt fangen hinter dem wort
krippe an die grippe oder influenza wird
oft mit einer erkältung in einen topf
geworfen schließlich wird eine erkältung
auch als grippaler infekt bezeichnet
durch diese namentliche ähnlichkeit wird
eine grippe oft als erkältung
missverstanden und unterschätzt es gibt
zwar ähnliche symptome wie husten
schnupfen kopf und gliederschmerzen aber
die grippe ist eine ganz andere liga
während eine erkältung zum beispiel
meist ohne fieber oder mit nur schwachem
fieber daherkommt haut die grippe eine
mit sehr starkem fieber auch der verlauf
ist anders eine erkältung fängt meist
mitteln kleinen kratzen im hals an die
symptome werden indem er schlimmer die
nächsten zwei drei tage hätten dann aber
auch wieder ab eine grippe die überfährt
ein so richtig von anfang an und kann im
krankenhaus oder im schlimmsten fall
sogar tödlich in die grippesaison
2017/18 war die stärkste und tödlichste
seit 30 jahren allein in deutschland
starben 25.000 menschen die zahl der
todesfälle für 2018 19 liegt noch nicht
vor aber das robert koch institut
spricht von einer eher moderaten
grippesaison die grippe ist also von
jahr zu jahr verschieden gefährlich
woran liegt das ja es gibt leider nicht
nur ein grippevirus sondern eine ganze
influenza familie also influenza familie
es gibt verschiedene grippeviren typen
die typen a und b sind die rede
für uns die sorgen jedes jahr für die
saisonale grippe vor diesem typen gibt
es aber auch noch unter typen also
subtypen die subtypen des typs a zum
beispiel werden nach der hn bezeichnung
benannt namen wie h1n1 oder h3n2 habt
ihr vielleicht schon mal gehört hab ihn
beziehen sich dabei auf die genaue
zusammensetzung der viren bzw auf die
genaue zusammensetzung ihrer oberfläche
die grippeviren könnt ihr euch
vorstellen wie gemeinde kugeln deren
oberflächen mit so kleinen spikes
versehen sind jeder dieser stacheln
besteht aus proteinen mit deren hilfe
die viren in unsere zellen eindringen
und sich darin vermehren können h&m
stehen jetzt für zwei verschiedene
oberflächenproteine hämagglutinin und
neuraminidase von hard n gibt es aber
verschiedene formen und je nachdem
welche forum auf der jeweiligen
virusoberfläche zu finden ist bekommt
das virus eine entsprechende bezeichnung
also noch mal es gibt verschiedene
virustypen die unterteilt werden
subtypen und die werden noch einmal
unterteilt in verschiedene stämme als
ihr seht es ist eine großfamilie und
diese familie hat es in sich
die bekämpfung der grippe die grippe ist
eine infektionskrankheit die prinzipiell
durch impfungen bekämpft werden kann
diese oberflächenproteine sind auch
sogenannte antigene das heißt in diesem
fall sie sind angriffspunkt für unser
immunsystem unser immunsystem kann
nämlich passend zu diesen virus
antigenen antikörper bilden übersteht
man die krankheit kann das immunsystem
dank dieser antikörper beim nächsten
virus angriff schnell reagieren und in
der regel zerstören wie bei anderen
impfungen kann man auch bei der
grippeimpfung den körper auch so einen
angriff vorbereiten ohne dass man die
echte krankheit durch und überstehen
muss bei einer grippe impfung
verabreicht man zum beispiel
abgeschwächte version der viren oder
auch nur teile der wehren die können die
krippe zwar nicht auslösen aber sie
enthalten trotzdem die antigene so dass
unser immunsystem die passenden
antikörper bilden kann
durch dieses ich sag mal immunsystem
training kann es zu typischen
impfnebenwirkungen kommen wie zum
beispiel rötung an der einstichstelle
oder abgeschlagenheit
leichtes fieber doch dieser beschwerden
vergehen danach ein paar chuck wieder
und der körper ist dann gewappnet wenn
der echte gefährliche erreger angreift
nur welcher ist der echte erreger unter
diesen vielen bzw welches ist der
richtige impfstoff ich ständige suche
nach dem grippeimpfstoff ihr wisst ja
wahrscheinlich also bei anderen
krankheiten muss man sich ein zweimal
impfen lassen vielleicht ist da noch
eine auffrischungsimpfung dabei aber man
hat lebenslagen schutz bei der grippe
ist das anders da muss man sich jedes
jahr jede saison aufs neue impfen lassen
die saisonale grippe wird wie gesagt von
grippe viren des typs a und b verursacht
das kann man jetzt noch bisschen weiter
konkretisieren es gibt vier verschiedene
grippeviren gruppen von denen aber
verschiedene variationen weltweit ihr
unwesen treiben so das ist ein riesen
act also auf der ganzen welt gibt es
labore die lassen sich patientenproben
zu schicken und untersuchen welche
konkreten kritisieren gerade umhergehen
in deutschland gibt es da das nationale
referenzzentrum für influenza und all
die internationalen labore übermitteln
dann ihre daten an die
weltgesundheitsorganisation und die sagt
dann jede grippesaison anpasst auf liebe
impfstoffentwickler die aktuellen
impfstoffe müssen die antigene folgen
der viren detail und das ist gar nicht
so einfach denn so ein impfstoff muss
natürlich erst mal hergestellt werden
das heißt für uns also für die
nordhalbkugel wird schon im februar
schätzen vorausgesagt welche grippeviren
in der kommenden grippesaison im umlauf
sein werden damit man eben noch bis
herbst genügend zeit hat um ausreichend
impfstoff herzustellen und deswegen
kommt es durchaus vor dass der impfstoff
nicht genau zu den tatsächlichen wären
passt und das ist leider noch nicht
alles die sache mit dem drift und shift
grippeviren sind sehr wandlungsfähige
viren es gibt dabei zwei wandlungs
mechanismen erstens antigen trifft denn
grippeviren sich vermehren also bei
ihrer reproduktion kommt es immer wieder
zu kleinen genetischen veränderungen
kopier fehlerchen wenn man so will und
die führen dazu dass die
oberflächenproteine
wären also die antigene sich leicht
verändern sind diese veränderungen klein
genug
dann können die antikörper unseres
immunsystems die senioren immer noch
erkennen aber diese antigen trifft
können sich mit der zeit an wolfen bis
die veränderung so groß sind dass unser
immunsystem das virus nicht mehr erkennt
auch deswegen muss man also jedes jahr
die viren neu bestimmen und die
impfstoffe anpassen der zweite
mechanismus ist der antigen shift und
der ist jetzt richtig gerne bei einem
schiff kombinieren sich genetische
eigenschaften verschiedener viren wobei
eine so wesentliche und abrupte
genetische veränderung auftritt das ein
ganz neues virus entsteht solche neuen
viren können extrem gefährlich sein weil
unser immunsystem das nicht kennt nichts
damit anfangen kann und wir also sehr
anfällig sind für diese viren so was
kann passieren wenn viren die
normalerweise tiere befallen wie zum
beispiel vögel oder schweine die
fähigkeit gewinnen auch menschen zu
infizieren
beispiel 2006 machte die vogelgrippe
schlagzeilen weil ein h5n1 virus das
eigentlich nur verfügen gefährlich war
dann doch menschen infiziert das virus
war für menschen zum glück generell
wenig ansteckend also weltweit
infizierten sich weniger als 900
menschen
aber mehr als die hälfte dieser menschen
verstarb also dass wir es war extrem
tödlich 2009 gab es dann panik gegen den
mexikanischen schweine diese
schweinegrippe war hoch ansteckend
weltweit infizierten sich rund 200
millionen menschen eine pandemie doch
werden glück das hoch ansteckende virus
führte nicht zu einem massensterben wie
etwa bei der spanischen grippe die 20
bis 50 millionen menschenleben forderte
starben an der schweinegrippe weltweit
weniger als 20.000 menschen also nur ein
winziger bruchteil der 200 millionen
infizierten aber das schweinegrippe
virus bleibt eine drohende gefahr weil
es sich auch in vögeln aufhalten kann
und wir wollen es nicht ausmalen was
passiert wenn da mal virus entstehen
sollte das so ansteckend ist wie die
schweinegrippe aber so tödlich wie die
vogelgrippe also nochmal viren
veränderungen die durch anti gehen
oft entstehen passieren graduell man
kann das beobachten und durch die
entwicklung von impfstoffen entsprechend
reagieren bei plötzlichen veränderungen
durch antigen shift können wir nur
hoffen dass die expertin den experten
irgendwie rechtzeitig es noch schaffen
gegenmittel rauszuhauen
oder wir können halt nur beten dass es
so glimpflich ausgeht wie letztes mal
aber kommen wir zurück zum täglichen
geschäft also beziehungsweise zum
jährlichen die wichtige frage ist doch
jetzt soll ich nicht gegen grippe impfen
lassen oder nicht wir wissen jetzt dass
grippeviren ein bisschen schicker sind
als manch andere viren weil es so viele
davon gibt und weil sie ständig
verändern an kann mit den impfstoffen
die tatsächlichen grippeviren knapp
verfehlen das bedeutet selbst wenn ich
gegen grippe geimpft bin kann ich immer
noch eine grippe bekommen also es gibt
auch bei den klassischen impfungen fälle
wo zum beispiel menschen antikörper
gegen bestimmte erreger nicht ausbilden
und sodann auch keinen impfschutz haben
aber das ist eher selten
also runter gebrochen kann man sagen die
klassischen impfungen die auch von der
stiko empfohlen werden sie bieten einen
sicheren schutz die grippeimpfung nichts
allerdings ist eine grippeimpfung die
leichter nehmen ist oft besser als gar
keine das heißt man kann sich trotzdem
anstecken aber dafür leidet man kürzer
unter der grippe also die symptome sind
milder oder man damit weniger oft im
krankenhaus oder senke das sterberisiko
ich habe mich dieses jahr grippe impfen
lassen weil ich als schwangere zu den
risikogruppen gehören für die die stiko
die grippeimpfung empfiehlt dazu zählen
unter anderem auch ältere menschen über
60 jahre
menschen mit chronischen krankheiten wie
zum beispiel diabetes oder mit
chronischen atemwegserkrankungen wie
asthma für uns kann eine grippe deutlich
stärker ausfallen und deutlich
gefährlicher ausgehen deren die mütter
geben ihre antikörper übrigens auch über
die plazenta an das baby weiter dass
dann somit auch geschützt wird
die grippeimpfung wird außerdem für
einige berufsgruppen empfohlen zum
beispiel für medizinisches personal um
sich selbst aber auch natürlich die
patienten zu schützen letztes jahr habe
ich mich übrigens auch grippe impfen
lassen im rahmen einer quarks reportage
über die grippeimpfung da ich jetzt ein
winter echte arbeit hatte ich erinnert
ihr euch an mein burnout video kam mir
das ganz gelegen denn so konnte ich das
risiko reduzieren durch eine grippe
flach zur liegend auszufallen aber für
mich als gesunde erwachsene frau ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit sehr hoch eine grippe
problemlos zu überstehen
deswegen gab es für mich jetzt es ja
keinen besonderen medizinischen bedarf
und deswegen empfiehlt die stiko auch
für gesunde erwachsene menschen die
grippeimpfung nicht aber ich wusste auch
dass ich mir mit so einer grippe impfung
nichts schlimmes antue entgegen mancher
gerüchte kann man durch eine
grippeimpfung keine grippe bekommen die
teile der wehren so wie sie bei der
grippeimpfung gespritzt werden sind dazu
wie gesagt gar nicht in der lage dieses
missverständnis kann aber entstehen wenn
man nach einer grippe-impfung eine
normale erkältung bekommt gegen die man
ja nicht geimpft ist
die man aber mit einer grippe
verwechselt oder das kann auch passieren
wenn man kurz vor der impfung oder kurz
nach der impfung sich mit der grippe
angesteckt hat dann kommt die impfung
quasi zu spät weil das ein bis zwei
wochen dauert bis der impfschutz
aufgebaut ist deswegen ist es wichtig zu
verstehen nur weil die stiko eine
impfung nicht empfiehlt heißt es nicht
dass sie davon abrät das betont das
robert-koch-institut hier auch nochmal
ganz ausdrücklich und wie bei allen
impfungen gilt impfung es immer auch ein
schutz unserer mitmenschen wenn ihr
jetzt zum beispiel jemanden in der
familie habt der gefährdet ist aber aus
irgendeinem grund nicht geimpft werden
kann
dann könnt ihr natürlich durch eure
eigene impfung auch schutz bieten also
nochmal die grippeimpfung kann vor
grippe schützen ist aber weniger
effizient als andere impfstoffe sind die
grippe impfung muss jedes jahr aufs neue
gemacht werden weil grippeviren
arschlöcher sind selbst wenn man sich
trotz impfung ansteckt können die
symptome deutlich milder ausfallen
menschen mit erhöhtem risiko sollten
sich unbedingt jedes jahr zu ihrem
eigenen schutz impfen lassen denn die
grippe ist
eine ernstzunehmende krankheit die
tödlich sein kann menschen außerhalb der
risikogruppen müssen sich nicht impfen
lassen sie können sich aber getrost dazu
entscheiden wenn sie andere schützen
wollen oder wenn sie einfach keinen bock
auf eine krippe haben falls das böse ist
also die meisten malek zuschauer gehören
nicht so eine risikogruppe wenn ihr euch
trotzdem impfen lassen wollt könnt ihr
euch mal erkundigen ob die krankenkasse
das bezahlt oder ob ihr arbeitgeber das
vielleicht anbietet das machen auch
immer mehr arbeitgeber weil die
natürlich auch kein interesse daran
haben dass ihr ausfall und teile dieses
video gerne mit euren eltern wenn die
schon 60 sein sollten oder großeltern
und mit schwamm und freunden und so
weiter ansonsten kommt gut durch den
winter beziehungsweise wir sehen uns ja
auch schon wieder der nächste woche bis
dahin bleibt sicher